(gentle music)
♪ Unforgettable ♪
♪ That's what you are ♪
♪ Though near or far ♪
♪ Like a song of love that clings to me ♪
♪ How the thoughts of
you does things to me ♪
♪ Never before ♪
♪ Has someone been more ♪
♪ Unforgettable ♪
♪ In every way ♪
♪ And forevermore that's how you'll stay ♪
♪ That's why darling it's incredible ♪
♪ That someone so unforgettable ♪
♪ Thinks that I am unforgettable too ♪
(gentle music)
(audience cheering)
- All right, all right, everybody,
welcome to "The Kelly Clarkson Show",
it's Martin Luther King Jr Day.
Give it up for my band y'all.
(audience cheering)
That was "Unforgettable" by Nat King Cole
who was an outspoken voice
in civil rights movement
as well as just one of
the greatest artists ever.
He was the first African-American
to host a network TV show,
I did not know that, I thought
that was cool information.
Throughout his career, he sued hotels
that wouldn't let him stay the night,
and in 1963, he marched on
Washington with Dr. King.
Before his passing,
Martin Luther King Jr actually
wrote him a telegram saying,
"You have my constant prayers,
I will be indebted to you
for your support in the struggle."
Which is an incredible
thing I didn't know as well.